jean loup dabadie on sait beaucoup de
choses de vous ce qu'on sait moi si vous
avez commencé en écrivant des romans et
des dieux du foyer le premier c'était
les yeux secs
alors comment ça se fait que ces romans
dont le premier a été saluée d'ailleurs
comme en ont parlé demorand comment se
fait-il que vous ayez pas continuer là
n'en est bien parce que
c'est vrai que l'on m'ait fait ce petit
honneur d'en parler j'étais encore à
signer en classe du moins à l'université
j'avais 18 ans pour le premier 19 ans
pour le second
oui ça n'a pas bien marché lors se
méritait pas davis alors jamais bien
pourquoi vous pensez vous les alliés
faire comme françoise sagan et comme
philippe sollers
peu de temps avant moi et
et peu de temps après ouais il y avait
eu beaucoup de succès que c'est dans les
lycées est ce moral en parler plus de 50
ans était fou littérature foot philo
d'air j'en parlais plus de leur livre
quand on était en philo parce que
le dire à ce moment là et
ceux d'entre nous qui rêvions des
grilles région de leur carrière 16 ans
le succès immédiat de cinq ans à
peut-être ruiner votre votre carrière de
romancier en soi ce qui est une quête
quelques années elle est divine elle est
divine là à la popote allant la courage
fou notamment le courage de publier
depuis cette époque où je t'aime jeune
homme en première et en philo et où on
lisait de bonjour tristesse un certain
sourire et les livres qui s'en est
ensuivie
on rêvait non seulement son destin mais
déjà décrit aussi librement et aussi
comme comme romy schneider plus tard
possible bellemans qu'elle est
évidemment
les uns et les autres les unes et les
autres nous n'avions pas tous la chance
d'être publié moi j'ai eu la chance
d'être publié
nous n'avions pas tous la chance d'avoir
du succès je n'ai pas eu le succès
devant la chambre
et comme je n'avais pas de sou il a
fallu que j'apprenne un métier et mais
j'ai été engagé par paul guimard va
lâcher talent alors son journal français
pas non plus et que vous avez bossé avec
averti sur les raisins verts qui était
une émission qui doit me fasciner les
goûts ce process les émissions qui a
informé mon goût et j'accuse
alors oui parce que j'étais plus en
avance que moi mais je la faisais
j'écrivais des textes
ouais inter je n'avais peur ou parce que
à part ma mère qui était qui a toujours
quelqu'un d'ultra moderne
tout le monde me disait
c'est la damnation et les enfants la
moulinette oui c'est surtout ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque
le mauvais goût ouais alors que
jean-christophe est une des premières
personnes à dire avez vous bien qu'il
aura trouvé l'huile mauvais goût du prix
compressés par le bruit pathologies
n'ont pas supporté mais parce que je
suis moi un chien essentielle qu'est ce
que tu dis un bien disait c'est pas toi
vais vous dire où nous voilà c'était le
sien et j'ai quelques années après dans
mes lectures j'ai vu qu'il avait un peu
pompé peut-être sans savoir mais on avis
parce que c'est quelqu'un de très
cultivé en le sachant sur sur dans jules
renard qui dit quelque part dans son
dans son journal wire du tour journal du
jura qui ont dit je suis pas sûr d'avoir
bon vous mais je débuterai sur la wii
cette phrase est patente lui céder sa
alors il nous apprenait sa aux uns aux
autres et parmi les débutants il y avait
les besoins c'est là vous êtes paye
c'est là qu'un sens que dans sa vie gene
convoyer un film vous avez écrit à la
télé est coupée par les pales et tibco
fait de la peine
voilà j'aime bien ce mot là ça
ça me fait de la peine je n'ai pas
systématique
si c'est j'ai pas dépasser par provoquer
ce que j'ai fait mais pas référence de
travail ça me ferait probablement je
n'en sais rien mais probablement plus de
peine si on coupe
les choses de la vie où vincent françois
paul et les autres que que le sauvage où
l éléphant ça trompe énormément parce
que ce sont des comédies mais encore que
je pense du purin matin j'aurais cru que
les fans de jean paul rappeneau d'yves
robert
les metteurs en scène de ses filles mais
mes amis aignan mais comment tu peux
dire ça à l'émotion est là même dès lors
qu'on fait rire par si vous y mettez
claude sautet sidérant vous bossez vous
travaillez comme ça aussi tout le temps
soit les musiciens 10 commandes atteint
alors à la fois les possibilités comme
ça alors oui c'est pour ça que c'est ça
que ce qu'ils montrent ce qui nous donne
le plus de 2 de traque avec ou toujours
avec la veille d'une peur d'acteur je me
suis toujours peur de commencer une
scène
cet après midi 2
de vendredi deux fois avoir fêté la fin
j'étais fan à 14 heures je vois pas
venir une autre fois le faire parce que
j'arrivais pas à aa à entrer dans une
scène que j'avais écrit que pas une de
plus difficile que j'ai à faire
mais c'est le même combat que pour les
acteurs c'est-à-dire une espèce d'envoi
sont que en plus de symbole national est
pas écrit de la part des anges elle n
est pas prête à l'attaqué et ce qui me
rassure c'est d'avoir une c'est d'avoir
une idée de des comédiens et des
comédiens qui vont jouer seulement vont
travailler parce que
qu'on a eu dans l'émission de jean
claude carrière ou ou gérants pacte qui
quand bras creux avec polanski
ils sont ensemble quand carrière travail
et kaufman licence en ou travailler tout
seul ou avec le réalisateur ça m'arrive
quand les réalisateurs sont le
réalisateur auteur quand je mange pas le
drap lawson wade robert faufile au
bureau quand j'ai eu l'honneur d'être
insolent hélas pour moi film pour lui on
travaille ensemble mais il se peut qu il
arrive aussi quelquefois ce qui est le
cas actuellement
que vous ayez une idée est que comme
pour un roman où ça mais c'est la même
chose c'est parce que et gérard ou ce
que jean-claude carrière vous ont dit
encore que j'ai vu la thermite
jean-claude que je ne me rappelle pas
que vous ayez parler de ça c'est la même
chose c'est le bouquin du film comme me
rappeler aux coques qu'on écrit bon
alors évidemment si on est ensemble si
vous êtes le réalisateur ou cissé où
l'auteur réalisateur se fait plaisir de
me parler et voir ma claque les bons
réalisateurs sont d'abord des bons
directeurs du d'auteur avant la nuit des
bandes jaunes d'acteurs de leurs regards
vous tirez votre drôlerie votre émotion
vos silences votre angoisse votre envie
de l'adoucir ce regard ou de l'allumer
sentir ça marche dans le gard de l'aude
voilà ça sent tout de suite que ce soit
le lendemain
mais il arrive quelquefois que pour
aller comme pour un livre comme pour une
pièce jointe ou cinq ans trouvé la
revoir ou parce que vous êtes tout seul
mais armé
quand j'entends des créatures qui
s'appelle forcing pour nathalie balle
mais c'est là qu'elle réalise pas encore
ce qui va leur demander mans de mon
écriture parce que j'ai commencé à
inventer mon histoire à la raconter aux
producteurs aux comédiens
c'est rare scénariste et non pas
tellement parce que quand vous aurez
fait plein de films plein de chansons
plein disquette je ne vous ai pas envie
de revenir la littérature nous faire un
roman
désespéré de 50 à 21 ans le terrain suis
fou de théâtre à cause des répétitions à
cause du travail physique avec les
acteurs mais ça n'empêche pas qu'il aida
mangerai vrai de vrai d'écrire des
livres mais je vais je suis pas sûr
d'être actuellement doué pour pour
écrire des livres ne dis pas que je le
jeu le saut passionnant pour le théâtre
comme ça au moins on peut se parler on
touche en ce moment on se rappelle au
téléphone si écrire un livre
c'est mon rêve puisque j tellement
lecteurs de livres du jeu monsieur vous
éclaire les gens vers messi jeu si la
proposerai que si je pouvais la nuit me
rappeler au téléphone pour corriger